Oh
there have been efforts to have
essentially atheist religions one was
utilitarianism the greatest good for the
greatest number and that didn't work
because it didn't have any good music
there really poor costumes no great
architecture and so on so it becomes a
kind of bureaucrats of religion but it's
not very exciting another effort was
Marxism of course and the the state
would be the equivalent of the church
and then the state would wither away and
everyone would live in wonderful harmony
with themselves and with nature and of
course it turned out to be completely
wrong because the communist model of
human behavior was a wrong model and so
we don't for this for this purpose we
don't have an adequate replacement if
you will this is not to say there
shouldn't be one people can in my
opinion anyway do whatever the hell they
want whatever the heaven they want but
the fact is that there is a a poverty of
effective intergenerational institutions
that would do what religions do for one
thing religions are very good about the
life cycle which we all have we get born
and there's usually a ceremony we have
First Communion or Bar Mitzvah or
initiation or whatever we then get
married and there's a ceremony for that
we we have children there's a ceremony
for that and then we die and and all of
these absolutely general phases of life
there's religion they have a plan they
have a piece of the prayer book that
deals with the issue they can usually
provide a kind of array of social
services at a relatively low cost
because it's wholesale they've done it
before and so that's one of the things
that religions succeed in doing and
while there are secular versions of that
they don't seem to be as prominent in
many environments as the religious one
again please understand I'm not
suggesting people should be religious or
shouldn't be but as a social scientist
it's my job to ask why are they
religious when they are and many people
are
there's a mixture of evidence here
there's for example there are always
these studies with somebody who's dying
or has a bad illness and everyone is
told to pray for so-and-so and the
expectation is that they'll live longer
or they'll get cured
well that's very poor there's no real
evidence that prayer in this sense
massive prayer helps an individual what
may help however his personal optimism I
wrote a book in 1979 I think called
optimism the biology of Hope because I
was interested in how humans succeed in
overestimating the odds in our favor and
I concluded somehow that if you're a
hunter-gatherer as we are you better get
up in the morning and think it's a great
day to catch an elephant because if you
get up in the morning and you say ah I
don't want to catch an elephant today
I'm going back to sleep well unless you
have an elephant in the freezer which
there wasn't you're going to be very
hungry by evening so there it was I'm
sure great selection for optimism in
Homo sapiens and the same is true in
sexual selection the my favorite
statement on this comes not from Darwin
who actually understood the process but
from George Bernard Shaw who said and
you can use any combination that
interests you he said love consists in
overestimating the difference between
one woman and another and if you don't
make that over-estimate whether it's to
a woman or to a man then you won't get
involved in the whole connection of
getting close to somebody and maybe
spending your life with them and maybe
having little replicas of yourselves
so optimism is important but it's a
personal issue whether there's a a kind
of formal advantage to religion I don't
know except that when we have crises
9/11 or whatever several things happen
people pray more they go to church and
furthermore as we could see especially
in New Orleans after Katrina the
churches were there to help well before
the government no you could say the
government was especially inept but the
fact is that religion
our setup for this so not sense people
who are religious might well be
healthier because they help each other
more